[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans point de
vue ou comme chaque jour nous nous
échangeons des convictions fortes de
préférence sur les sujets d'actualité
nous allons parler aujourd'hui de la
pétition signée par un certain nombre de
parlementaires surtout de gauche qui
veulent que le gouvernement explique qui
va profiter exactement quelles sont les
contribuables et dans quel niveau qui va
donc profiter de la baisse de l'is f
nous allons aussi parler de sécurité à
la suite du discours d' emmanuel macron
cet après midi aux forces de sécurité
intérieure le président de la république
est il crédible sur ses registres dans
un contexte de terrorisme toujours
extrêmement présent nous allons parler
aussi de la chine puisque voilà un homme
qui n'a pas de problème de sécurité sexy
jean ping le secrétaire général du parti
communiste chinois qui ouvrait le 19e
congrès de son parti alors que son pays
connaît une situation économique aussi
florissante que la vie politique est
fermés et verrouillés à triple tour et
puis nous parlerons de l'état islamique
à la suite de l'annoncé de la libération
de jaca en attente pour autant fini avec
ce mouvement état islamique la défaite
militaire est elle aussi une défaite
idéologique politique tactique
nous allons en reparler avec nos quatre
invités bonsoir électorale donc très
heureux de vous accueillir dans point de
vue vous êtes et la directrice de la
revue des deux mondes votre revue dans
son dernier numéro publié un dossier sur
qu'est-ce que le maquereau nisme vaste
question en règle générale vous êtes
aussi écrivain romancière votre dernier
roman l'étrangère est paru en 2007 chez
flammarion
bonsoir alexis lacroix
bonsoir il vous est toujours directeur
délégué de la rédaction de l'express a
changé selon nous nous réjouissons et
votre hebdomadaire publié en une cette
semaine un dossier exceptionnel sur new
york new york que la rebelle 28 pages
j'imagine un numéro à avoir dans sa
poche pour les prochaines vacances
indispensable
pour tous les amateurs des états unis
bonsoir verte' bayard et rédacteur en
chef au service économie entreprises du
figaro les célèbres pages saumon et
votre confrère du figaro renault gérard
et aussi avec nos bons soirs d'eau soit
vous êtes le chroniqueur international
du figaro vous êtes également l'auteur
de quel diplomatie pour la france paru
aux éditions du cerf et vous êtes aussi
un collaborateur au combien éminent de
la revue des deux mondes
nous commençons donc par parler de cette
initiative rendue publique ce matin dans
libération c'est une pétition d'un
certain nombre de responsables
politiques essentiellement des
parlementaires du parti communiste de la
france insoumise et du parti socialiste
qui veulent en savoir un petit peu plus
sur l'impact fiscal pour les
contribuables les plus riches du
démantèlement de l' isf
l'un des signataires de cette pétition
françois ruffin le député la france
insoumise de la somme s'en est expliqué
ce matin sur france info
on n'est même pas sur le fond du dossier
là ce qu'on réclame simplement c'est une
exigence de transparence de savoir à qui
profite ces mesures fiscales et donc je
pense que sur ce point là je suis plus
surpris de l'absence de députés de en
marche par exemple qui n'ont pas qu'ils
ont été contactés par libération et
quand et qui n'ont pas signé ce texte on
se cherche à sable ans à savoir la
vérité des prix pour ainsi dire à qui ça
va profiter alors l'objet l'observatoire
français des conjonctures économiques
penser que à peu près la moitié des
baisses d'impôts bénéficierait aux 10%
les plus riches ou est-ce qu'on en est
il ya eu des petites modifications ou
est-ce qu'on en est là dessus merci
d'ailleurs est ce qu on sait qui va
profiter et et à quelle hauteur de ses
de ces économies d'impôts avec les sf
dont on rappelle qu'il est reformater
pour ne plus appliquer désormais que co
fortune mobiliers immobiliers dont et
non plus mobilières alors heureusement
nominativement on ne sait pas qui va
bénéficier de la fin de l' isf
par définition on a un effet de
proportionnalité qui nous dit que
évidemment la masse de d2 la suppression
de l'sf va se porter sur les plus hautes
fortunes c'est une évidence mathématique
voilà donc la question c'est de savoir
qui est ce qu on veut exactement
trouvait derrière cette transparence
hockey réclamé aujourd'hui par françois
ruffin évidemment des angles d'attaqué
supplémentaires pour combattre cette
réforme de la dsf
le président de la chambre le président
des riches évidemment et de la même
façon on a un souvenir ce qui s'était
passé pour le boucler fiscal de nicolas
sarkozy qui était mal ficelé quelque
part puisque effectivement là c'était le
trésor qui faisait un chèque de
remboursement de cette y est c'est fait
donc on avait dit madame bettencourt va
toucher un chèque de autant de dizaines
de millions d'euros et évidemment ça
avait eu un effet dévastateur
donc si aujourd'hui on pouvait tomber
sur une liste qui nous disent de nouveau
la famille bettencourt autre française
va bénéficier d'une réduction d'impôt de
temps évidemment ça aurait un impact sur
l'opinion publique extrêmement important
voilà maintenant on se retranche
derrière le secret fiscal pour éviter
cette
forme de listes qui serait pas très
honorable il ya quand même eu un début
de réponse sans les noms de bruno le
maire le ministre de l'économie qui a
dit on va redistribuer à priori 400
millions d'euros exactement de ras 400
millions d'euros qui ne seront plus
payés par les mille premiers
contribuables de france
alors comme je suis le dieu du calcul
mental ça fait quatre cent mille euros
par contribuable
est ce que ces sont des chiffres qui
vous choque valérie toranian mais vous
vous dites que toute façon pour que la
france repart qu'il faut baisser les
impôts en particulier pour les riches
puisque c'est eux qui tirent l'économie
non mais je trouve que surtout il ya
quelque chose de grotesque parce que
inversons inversant la question vous
avez posé et ceara qui voilà qui va
bénéficier de tous les effets en quoi le
fait qu'à un moment donné on ait voulu
taxer à 75 % les revenus en quoi ça à
bénéficient à l'économie française et en
quoi ça fait vraiment rentrer des
recettes
ça fait partie ça fait s'exiler beaucoup
de contribuables français qui du coup
c'est une réalité ont pris leurs
habitudes ailleurs et au plus tellement
envie non plus tellement envie de
rentrer et de se réinvestir dans
l'économie du pays donc je trouve qu'on
est un peu dans ce débat sur des fraudes
des faux problème parce que finalement
ce que ça avait rapporté à l'état ses
recettes fiscales ce n'était pas tant
que ça c'est c'est cet isf est
aujourd'hui bon ben voila je pense que
après chacun est dans son rôle c'est à
dire que rufin face le sans culotte et
demandent des listes et des noms bon ben
voilà c'est normal il est dans son rôle
on dise que c'est le président des
riches mais c'est vrai qu'en ce moment
il a une politique
voilà mes mais en même temps on est un
peu à la ramasse avec cette mesure donc
le fait que aujourd'hui et plus que je
crois l'espagne et la france qui soit
sur cette supprimer un qui n'est pas
super bon ben voilà on est dans une
mondialisation dans un monde
concurrentiel faut bien que ça avance
voilà mais qu'est ce que ça nous avait
apporté le fait d'avoir fait ces mesures
c'est surtout sa jeudi on est on avait
une économie qui toute façon
était dans une grande pénibilité
espérons c'est un pari un peu pascalien
des et josé petit espérant que les
riches contribueront
espérons le qu'ils investiront et qui
disait que je faisais injecteront dans
l'économie mais en même temps le fait
qu'ils reviennent
c'est plutôt un bon signe pour le
travail ou ses envies des consommateurs
dans leur pays plutôt qu'ailleurs je
trouve que et puis le break site est
aussi un point qui va favoriser
peut-être que ce qui fait partir
d'angleterre reviennent donc tout ça ça
va peut-être faire un ensemble de choses
voilà c'est un peu un pari on sait pas
ce qu'il va se passer exactement mais
bon c'est vrai vous parlera et mauvais
si vous parlez des sans culottes de la
france insoumise alexis lacroix allez
vous être le sans culotte de point de
vue vous voulez côté marrant parce que
quand il est question des sans culottes
ils se tournent toujours vers moi alors
je pense qu'il faut que ça c'était un
renault gérard où vous et je ne sais pas
pendant les chefs pour bien je le ferai
après on interrompt alors c'est vrai que
moi sur le principe ciblé j'ai jamais
été aussi vent debout contre l' isf
que certaines voix disent on
traditionnelles de la presse de la
droite
après tout bon cette voie là c'est comme
le figaro par exemple par exemple mais
mais comment vous dire c'est un cetain
dissensus kiné qui n'est pas une amicale
maintenant on décide de le supprimer je
pense qu'effectivement c'est plutôt une
bonne mesure et je suis assez d'accord
avec tout ce que dit valérie c'est un
pari c'est le pari de mâcon bon ce qu'il
faut qu'on la compagnie on verra bien ce
que ça donne toute façon des cibles et
on est dans le brouillard de l'histoire
on sait pas tout ce que tout ça va
donner peut-être que ça ne donnera rien
peut-être qu'on va pas de véritable
reprise de l'économie mais concernant la
le l'argument qui vient d'être avancée
par marie je suis d'accord effectivement
on a fait s'exiler disons au nom d'une
chasse aux riches et d'une
redistribution trop systématique
on a fait s'exiler beaucoup de gens qui
sont des producteurs de richesses et
dont la france d'aujourd'hui a besoin
mais un mot peut être plus ciblés pour
prendre un peu de commentaires
d'altitude par rapport aux purs débat
économique
moi ce qui me frappe dans la
l'initiative de françois ruffin de ses
amis du parfum de
venu disons d'une coeur de l'ex parti de
gauche et aussi des socialistes a
maintenant mais j'aime ça l'ancien des
prisons parti socialiste puisque
effectivement michel sapin là vous êtes
dans le coeur de la hollande y 1 ce qui
reste de la hollande y cette initiative
comprend ils sont dans le rôle encore
une fois oublié on peut pas reprocher à
des gens de gauche d'être de gauche et
c'est pas moi qu'il ferait ici à point
de vue néanmoins je crois qu'ils sont en
train de succomber à l'une des passions
fondamental que contre lesquels
d'ailleurs nietzsche qui est un auteur
que vous aimez je pense guillaume avait
mises en garde avaient loué cette
passion c'est la passion du ressentiment
voilà je crois qu'il y a aujourd'hui
même si je suis plus réservé que vous
sur la nocivité de l'iace f
je crois qu'il ya aujourd'hui au poste
de commande en france dans de nombreuses
formations politiques mais aussi chez
les journalistes et intellectuels qui a
une passion ressentiment talent et ça
c'est très dangereux parce que ce très
souvent dans l'histoire de la france a
fait le lit non pas de plus de
démocratie mais de davantage de
servitude renaud girard
oui moi je suis entièrement contre
l'impôt sur la fortune et c'est une
contradiction très profonde en fait des
socialistes qui appartient de
de quatre du gouvernement rocha vont
libéralisé et donc vont adopter l'europe
des marchés l'investissement au vin etc
et qui ensuite vont mettre des taxes
prohibitif par rapport à la concurrence
aucun des grands pays européens quand
même voir les choses qui sont qui ce
qu'ils soient bien gouvernées par les
sociaux démocrates ou par la droite
aucun des grands pays européens et que
ce soit l'italie que ce soit réellement
l'angleterre n'a l'impôt sur la fortune
aujourd'hui si vous voulez aller au
portugal
quel que soit votre richesse vous payer
un impôt forfaitaire de 100 mille euros
et il y a il faut dire les choses comme
comme elles sont
il y à une concurrence fiscale en europe
c'est comme ça l'or n'a pas été capable
de faire de la moralisation jusqu'à par
ailleurs cet impôt je parle sous le
contrôle de mon et liberty mais n'a
jamais rapporté plus de 10 milliards
d'euros
or il coûte c'était un des calculs qui
ont été faits il coûte en impôts que non
pas payer en impôt normes ou que nos
papilles et les gens qui sont partis
près de 40 milliards d'euros les gens
qui les gens qui paient l'impôt sera
fournie mais aussi d'autres impôts et
leurs familles mais aussi dans la potion
alors souvenu fatou des autres impôts
maintenant ils sont partis donc il ne
paie plus évoqué il ya une à une il ya
eu en fait un exode à
la leçon des entrepreneurs français a
été vidée on a vu des états-majors
d'entreprise qui ceux qui sont partis
par exemple je sais que toute une partie
d'état-major d'air liquide est parti
ailleurs mais pas m'aimer par exemple en
allemagne simplement c'est pas un pays y
voyez la vie oui comme un peu de
socialistes et donc c'est une folie
c'est une folie que les socialistes
n'ont pas voulu voir monsieur moscovici
en suspens tournis que les gens
partaient et ils ont jamais et même je
me souviens ou de jean pierre jouyet
directeur adjoint de cabinet de jospin
c'était il ya longtemps et je ne
rencontre le feu dans la rue et judy
mais cet impôt est débile il m'a dit
j'aime bien d'accord avec toi renommée
ils n'ont rien fait ils le savaient ils
savaient que c'est à pau il est un impôt
effectivement du ressentiment pour moi
l'impôt ça sert pas à punir les gens
lincou ne doit pas punir alors
simplement être efficace c'est-à-dire
donner des ressources à l'état et il ya
beaucoup de pays
par exemple je suis saoul ou qui peut
impliquer marché où les gens trouvent ça
normal
ep volontiers le leur apport et même aux
états unis les gens payent volontiers
leurs impôts il faut pas avoir un
système comme ça et la taxation 4%
arrêtées étaient des montots merci
renaud je vais vous redonner la parole
mais je suis un peu effondré parce que
vous êtes quasiment tous d'accord
heureusement valentin pilates est là
deux représentants du figaro.fr valent
en tant qu est ce qu on pense sur les
réseaux sociaux de cette initiative
consistant à ajouter en quelque sorte
les contribuables les plus riches
écoute écoute et guillaume si vous
pensez ce matin en fait créé le hashtag
ballons sont riches et bien erreur il
existe déjà c'est vrai qu'on croyait
qu'on avait inventé le nom pour mettre
en banque mais sauf que ça existe déjà
il existe bien même si raf nous dit
balançant riches au nom s'il vous plaît
pas maintenant nous qu'on ne comparons
pas l'incomparable entre balances ton
port qui n'est pas un buzz a décliné et
bien raf je suis désolé mais si il est
décliné avec guy
avec après l'hypocrisie balances ton
port libellant ce balancement riche la
délation sans limites de la gauche et
que c'était une de libération qui nous
dit impôts des riches dites nous la
vérité on à christophe qui renchérit sur
cette une de libération
la france derniers pays communistes
haine du riche et de la réussite
luc addor quant à lui s'en prend à
mélenchon balance temps riche mélange
mêlant chant qui nous parle de lutte
ouvrière tout en voyageant en classe
affaires
allez on élargit un petit peu avec yves
sur notre site internet qui s'en prend à
l'amendement du modem défendu par
beyrouth sur l' isf qui consiste à
maintenir l' isf est à exclure les
titres de sociétés dont qui veut nous
dit par pitié que l'on arrête ces
imbécilités digne d'une philosophie
communiste c'est un impôt qui n'existe
nulle part ailleurs dans le monde on
terminera juste avec cette petite touche
d'humour de caméléon
moi je ne suis pas jalouse des riches
mais des gens qui arrivent à avoir une
place dans le métro pendant les heures
de pointe
on a une pensée donc particulière pour
alexis lacroix qui va devoir traverser
tout paris pour venir nous voir mais
vint le temps file à petit vous dis je
traverse et paris en métro parce que là
non tout à l'heure on parlait des
renault gérard parler des socialistes
enfin faut pas oublier quand même que la
droite avec sarkozy là elle concernée
oui il faut pas oublier non plus je
dirais que ça c'est quand même important
est pas mon sort et par peur justement
de ce que les classes populaires et de
ce que voilà toute cette mythologie
autour de la richesse de la haine de
l'argent keita qui en france est très
forte
hmm hmm sarkozy eu peur de ça voilà il
faut qu'on soit soyons soyons équitable
quand même et donc le moment est
solennel je crois qu'il faut quand même
dire on ajout est pas contre ce que
renault a dit mais on en a point de ce
qu'il vient de dire sur les socialistes
que la lucidité des socialistes elles
existent sur les failles de liesse f ça
fait longtemps d'ailleurs que ce
discours a été tenu
c'est vrai peut-être un peu à l'étouffée
ou à couvert néant
- est lucide et vous vous posez pas la
leur dénier historiquement pourquoi ça
n'a pas été fait mais c'est tout
simplement parce que il ya une fracture
culturelle une fracture économique des 2
go je vous le savez très bien
or effectivement il ya toujours cette
espèce de mythe du programme d honneur
alors cette réalité rend absolument
casser donc semis des somites durable du
programme commun a obligé une partie de
la gauche sociale démocrate social
libéral aménager le maintien de cet
impôt envers et contre tous mais bercy
est ce que vous croyez que les français
sont toujours cette même jalousie
sociale est ce que on regarde pas
autrement les grands patrons qu est-ce
qui vous disent vous les voyez toute la
journée
est-ce qu'ils ont le sentiment que il ya
un peu plus d'admiration et un peu moins
de jalousie sur eux en france
aujourd'hui on sent bien qu'on a basculé
dans le sentiment général un regard de
l'entrepreneur rien donc la création
d'entreprise etc
ça c'est quelque chose qui est devenu
beaucoup plus acceptable est beaucoup
plus enthousiasmant dans l'esprit des
français
la fortune et le grand patronat c'est
encore autre chose et là on a encore on
a encore du ressentiment et la
difficulté à accepter à accepter ces
situations-là ce différend voit bien que
les réseaux sociaux le climat que crée
cette cet appel
à délation entre guillemets et assez
assez détestable et chaussures
les socialistes et vous disais qu'il
fallait être équitable moi je suis quand
même un petit peu choqué de voir michel
satin et françois hollande depuis séoul
s'accrocher sur cette histoire 10 h f
pour des elles sont quand même pas
oublier quand françois hollande dit
cette façon de faire de la fiscalité va
créer en effet de paralyser fans
empêcher le pays de se mobiliser quand
on sait ce qu'on souvient de ce qu'elle
a été l'effet du budget 2012
concocté par françois hollande michel
sapin et christian encore avec lui mais
voilà on a quand même cassé la
croissance l'emploi et l'investissement
de façon durable dans ce pays à ce
moment là et donc je pense que les deux
sont aujourd'hui qui viennent de là ne
sont peut-être pas de chuter je suis pas
le nombre de ces demandes et le parti
socialiste dont j'ai défoncé en 30
secondes je défonce françois je le fais
souvent d'ailleurs à voutré votre
émission j'aime bien cet exercice là je
pense que je suis d'accord avec ce que
vous dites mais je pense que les
remarques acerbes de hollande sont à
prendre
alors la poudre dans un sens plus
politicien il évidemment il veut après
la trahison ce qu'il estime être la
trahison de cavaliers de massane franche
sur une leçon de fiscalité me paraît
normal veut
après la trahison ski dont il estime
avoir été victime l'année dernière il
veut corriger sa copie vaut aux
candidats macron et donc c'est ça
s'inscrit dans une démarche politicienne
quand j'étais à lui dire tu m'as bien
emmerdé l'an dernier dès maintenant
c'est moi qui vais tomber devant la
france entière à la fois at il trahi
alors dit la perception de long la
perception parce que personne n'a
empêché hollande de se présenter devant
les français je regardais comment j'ai
bien géré ce pays
regardez combien j'ai bien combattu
chômage et donc réaliser moi classes
populaires
qu'est-ce qui nous il joue avec macron
socket chirac avec sarkozy c'est à dire
bien
merci beaucoup à faire pilote je vous
propose de passer à un autre sujet celui
de la sécurité le président de la
république était cet après midi devant
les représentants des forces de sécurité
intérieure pour un discours important je
vous propose d'en écouter tout de suite
un extrait je vais être très clair avec
vous je vous demande d'être fort et
juste juste n'est jamais être faible
mais nous devons une rigueur implacable
dans le contexte qui est le nôtre
sur chacun des sujets que j'aborderai et
donc c'est l'application à la tâche le
sens de la mission une exigence
collective que je souhaite aujourd'hui
que nous puissions partager
alors pour être tout à fait franc et
honnête et complet le discours d'
emmanuel macron ne se limitait pas à ces
généralités
certes généreuse mais qui pas très
engageante il ya aussi de la part du
président la république l'annoncé d'un
nouveau plan national contre la
radicalisation valérie toranian on a
quand même envie d'ajouter un de plus
pour l'interrogation plus c'est une
manière aussi de montrer alors justement
peut-être que comme hollande macro
arrive avec une étiquette parle de
droite
encore que ce qui m'est crédit ça dépend
des dossiers est ce qu'il est crédible
sur la question de la sécurité
je crois qu'il a surtout un ministre de
l'intérieur qui est crédible sur cette
question comme hollande avait un
ministre de l'intérieur qui était
crédible cette question et valls aussi
en tant que premier ministre était et
que finalement il est devenu créé
crédible au cours de son quinquennat
alors oui peut-être une loi de plus mais
en même temps j'ai pas exactement les
détails les contours de ski
et de ce qui va en résulter mais je
pense que la question de la sécurité
elle reste elle est importante on va
parler tout à l'heure de draka et de
dèche mais voilà on sait ce qui s'est
passé à marseille ça ment tout ça prouve
que on a besoin quand même d'avoir une
politique de renseignement de police qui
soit efficace et qui est né dans ce sens
là je pense que globalement macron va
dans le bon sens j'ai pas l'impression
qu'il va être en fait pas laxistes non
il va pas être laxiste il est
et puis là c'est quand même volonté est
même assez déterminés et sur ces
questions là notamment il n'a pas envie
en tout cas de faire moins bien que ce
café hollande et finalement le bilan de
hollande a été sur ces questions de
sécurité plutôt bon vous parlez de
marseille il ya une mesure en tout cas
concrètes qu'on connaît déjà dans la
politique que de sécurité du président
de la république c'est sa volonté de
rétablir ce qu'on appelait à l'époque la
police de proximité est ce que ce sera
suffisant dans un contexte de violence
et de délinquance qu'on connaît
actuellement en france pas forcément
partout c'est en tout cas l'avis de
samia ghali
elle est sénatrice des bouches du rhône
élus de marseille c'est pour ça que je
vous en parlais elle est sociale et
c'est à l'été ce matin dans territoire
d'infos sur public sénat on nous parle
aujourd'hui d'une police de proximité a
admis en 2018 dont acte sauf que on va
envoyer une police de proximité
aujourd'hui dans des endroits où le
danger est omniprésent
quand j'ai lu danger je parle je sais je
mesure mes mots et que je suis pas sûr
que ce soit bien de lui faire tout coque
de 7,6 et pas dans quelle forme ça va
sûrement la bonne réponse adaptée non
magique spécifiquement des quartiers
s'étaient bien au moment où on avait
fait un gros travail sur la sécurité
aujourd'hui dans l'état dans lequel sont
certains quartiers je déconseille de m
da police de proximité dans ces
quartiers je vous le dis c'est ça fait
presque peur ce que ce que dit la
sénatrice avenir en gros la violence est
telle aujourd'hui que la police ne
suffit plus d'ailleurs si mes souvenirs
sont bons c'est elle qui demandait qu'on
envoie l'armée dans certaines dans
certains quartiers pour les quartiers
qu'elle évoque
elle pense probablement aux 15e et 16e
arrondissements de marseille quartiers
nord de marseille avec artie comme cela
dont il est lui même pour ceux ci à
d'autres quartiers naturellement il ya
des territoires perdus perclus de
terrorisme sur l'ensemble de l'espace
territorial de la république y compris
bien sûr en ile-de-france est d'abord
peut-être même en ile de france
elle pense à tous ces quartiers là dans
la région rhône-alpes aussi bien sûr
dans la conurbation le lyonnaise et
peut-être même toulousaine dont elle
pense à tous ces territoires qui sont
effectivement aujourd'hui des poches de
radicalisation islamiste et de
djihadisme il est évident ça c'est vrai
elle a raison ça megally cunlhat le
rétablissement d'une police de proximité
par parenthèse annulé détricoter comment
dire congédié par nicolas sarkozy n'y
suffira pas néanmoins je crois que
macron va dans le bon sens
hélas il ne l'assument pas bien sûr il
nous fait croire qu'il n'y a aucun lien
avec françois hollande mais je suis
d'accord avec valérie il s'inscrit
fondamentalement dans la suite dans la
poursuite dans le sillage de la ligne
régaliennes qui a été celle de hollande
et de son premier mini de son deuxième
premier ministre manuel valls mais il ne
veut pas trop que ça se disent mais nous
on ne dit pas ce qu'on est là pour dire
la vérité aux français
crise nous explique qu'il ya des
quartiers entiers qui pose problème à
marseille socialiste
ce que je ne comprends pas alors que les
dirigeants la police ont suggéré ça je
colons et monsieur l'intérieur voilà on
met les intérieurs présent république ce
que je ne comprends pas c'est pourquoi
on ne suspend pas le regroupement
familial de mer tout à fait certaine la
population immigrée française est un
problème d'intégration c'est tout à fait
clair que même personne ni même
peut-être que libération ne le nie pas
quoi et donc pourquoi ne seront pas
prend une décision assez simple on
suspend le regroupement familial
en attendant que cette intégration se
fasse quitta le reprend parce qu'il ya
une cour de justice européenne
non je ne sais pas quel traité on peut
d'ailleurs tout à fait les traités
européens qu'on ne respecte pas par
ailleurs parce qu'on a un autre traité
qui nous dit qu'on n'a pas le droit de
d'avoir plus de 3% de déficit du budget
et nous les dépassons allègrement je ne
comprends pas face à une situation comme
celle qui viennent est écrite par cette
sénatrice céline de marseille pourquoi
est ce que on accepte que le flux
continu vers ces quartiers et je vous
rappelle d'ailleurs que le
soffer tunisien qui a tué 90 personnes
ou 14 juillet à nice était venu par le
regroupement familial
tout le monde ne fait pas ce lien entre
eux entre l'immigration notamment par le
regroupement familial est là et la
délinquance et le terrorisme
mais c'est surtout je pense que c'est un
régal y parle aussi et peut-être même
beaucoup plus du banditisme et de la
drogue 2 et 2 et des l'extrême
criminalité c'est le je crois elle
évoque à mots couverts car et je sais
qu'un élu de la république est truffé
jihad attendait est ce qu'elle évoque je
crois avec précision elle a déjà bien
existe entre évidemment le méchant je
crois qu'elle évoque ses amours le vite
pour être très précis et elle ne peut
pas le dire comme ça car elle est l'élue
de ses quartiers ce qu'elle évoque c'est
le lien entre le gangstérisme
vous avez raison et le phénomène
terroriste elle évoque savent
précisément elle ne peut pas le dire
comme ça donc bien que des journalistes
comme nous parler de cette manne et
l'arrière pardon sont aussi des
gangsters
puisqu'on parle gangstérisme qui ont des
cartes d'identité française c'est donc
la question aujourd'hui c'est que c'est
dé deuxième génération des troisième
génération donc celle du recoupement je
sais pas si elle est pertinente ou si
elle empêcherait en tous cas sa vision
de trait
ce que je dis c'est que le celui qui est
assassiné avec son camion
les 14 juillet est venu par le
regroupement familial ça c'est tout à
fait clair pour celui qui a tué lors de
la journée de noël à berlin avec un
camion a également était venu avec le
flot d'immigrés merkel 2000 crise est là
dessus on peut avoir un doute sur
l'analyse que je voulais c'est de la
part ou tout de suite sur la liste de
renault c'est que il insiste sur les
migrations je crois que le phénomène
c'est pas ça le problème c'est vraiment
dans les quartiers ce gangstérisme qui
est une sorte de propédeutique
éventuelle à l'action terroriste c'est
là-dessus qu'il faut réfléchir et
évidemment de ce point de vue là je suis
pas tellement contre cette mesure de
macron je pense qu'il a raison de
rajouter les îlotiers alors ils seront
peut-être un puissant mais en tout cas
au moins ils pourront faire remonter des
informations sur la réalité de cette
porosité en tout cas merci bailleur la
porosité justement entre les diverses
formes de problèmes de sécurité qu'on
peut avoir de vue la petite délinquance
fin de vue de problème d'intégration à
la petite délinquance à la grande
délinquance et à la radicalisation
emmanuel macron tout à l'heure on a
parlé dans son discours ça faisait
partie je pense ddd des points
intéressants de ce discours de ce que
j'en ai honte pour la partie que j'en ai
entendu c'est qu'effectivement il a mis
plusieurs problèmes sur la table
simultanément on a souvent des
dirigeants politiques qui s'adresse aux
policiers avec un discours sécuritaire
aux associations avec un discours
d'accueil de
de lumière des migrants et c'est un
espèce de saucissonnage comme ça des
problèmes éthiques
là aujourd'hui il a eu une vision un
petit peu à 366 à la fois sa qualité son
défaut parce que du coup ça fait un
discours qui était un peu long mais ça
avait au moins 7 cette vertu là après il
ya un côté un peu yakafokon
effectivement et donc tout sera dans
l'exécution dans cette recherche
d'efficacité qui là qu'il a souhaité et
c'est là que ça devient extrêmement
compliqué que je suis pas sûr qu'une
mesure en particulier puisse apporter
une réponse
c'est tout à fait ce monsieur c'est tout
à fait sont bien sûr tenait la fusion de
mesures mais aucune démarche symbolique
rivaux décante enfin il faut prendre
vous prendre en considération ce que dit
cette sénatrice et ses quartiers qui ne
sont pas intégrés
d'accord ils n'ont pas intégré dans la
société française qui ne ne faut pas ce
qu'ils font pas leur les lois de la
société française vous souvenez de cet
incident dans un accident près de la
banlieue parisienne et on avait ne fait
pas le français à quelqu'un qui veut
qu'il voulait faire un qui voulait faire
un constat et ne fait pas le français
puisqu'il était je crois lanthier contre
un contre un contre un
un immigré d'ailleurs d'origine en tout
cas un kabyle d'origine d'origine
immigrée qui voulait faire un constat et
ne fait pas le français donc dans ces
quartiers là il ya comme un problème
d'intégration de respect de la loi
française d'assimilation la française de
détérioration de la loi française que
vous n'avez pas que vous n'avez vous que
vous n'aviez peut-être pas ailleurs mais
vous n'avez pas aujourd'hui au larzac ou
ou en lorraine ou en bretagne vous
voulez et ça c'est un vrai problème et
donc je pense que ce n'est pas
nécessaire effectivement mais je ne
comprends pas pourquoi les politiques
n'osent pas se prononcer là dessus c'est
pas nécessaire de continuer ce fut alors
c'est intéressant ce que tu
m'accompagnes dans son discours aussi de
lutte contre la ghettoïsation de
certains quartiers dont qui il ouvre la
focale berti d'ailleurs on a une
question du go qui nous dit comment elle
manana compte peut-il être crédible en
ne créant que 10000 postes dans la
police
est ce que votre avis la réponse elle
est avant tout une réponse de
d'effectifs et de budget ça fait partie
savon pour la sécurité comme ça vaut
pour d'autres missions de l'état et en
particulier l'école on a bien vu que le
nombre de postes n'étaient pas
un indicateur fiable ensuite de la
réussite d'une politique qui avraiment
au changement de logiciel a opéré là
dessus pour tout le monde y compris pour
les forces de l'ordre après c'est de la
redistribution des fonctions à
l'intérieur des effectifs de sécurité
[Musique]
peut-être oui on a évidemment un
mouvement qui doit s'opérer avec ses
classiques 1 mais moins de personnes
dans les bureaux plus de personnes sur
le terrain on doit avoir une utilisation
plus massive de tout ce que peut nous
apporter aujourd'hui la technologie
on a aussi on a parlé ça commence à
venir peut-être une forme de
privatisation de certaines fonctions ça
ça va être extrêmement sensible aussi
des demandes on a parlé pour les radars
sur les autoroutes
et quand même quelque chose de très très
très restreinte allait en démissionner
des forces de sécurité aujourd'hui pour
sa part effectivement et wlan a beaucoup
parlé au moment des attentats mais la
question du renseignement a livré al
réadapter l'enseignement et qui n'est
pas fonction du nombre de personnes
qu'on est technologique
un moment donné les écoutes faut des
gens c'est qu'ils savent qu'ils sachent
les interpréter qu'il connaissait les
langues les différentes langues les
différentes origines il y a un vrai
travail pour qu'on puisse continuer à
être effectivement en sécurité et un
travail de fourmi d'enseignement qui est
extrêmement important je vous propose de
traverser la planète pour nous retrouver
en chine xi jingping le
secrétaire-général du parti communiste
chinois
ouvrez ce matin le 19e congrès de son
parti avec un discours fleuve qui a duré
plus de trois heures rassurez vous on va
vous en mettre trois heures on vous en
mets juste un petit morceau la
philosophie en gros c'est la chine est
une grande puissance économique et ça ne
fait que commencer
écoutez le téléchargement par john lee
chez vous au pigeon tienne chichan
d'olivier of things in you tube i can do
lee si elle joue son maintien
on agira il ya une ambition forte qui
ont été annoncées par le patron du parti
communiste chinois en termes de
développement économique ou
classiquement que un pays ne peut pas se
développer économiquement et en une
dictature est en fait quand il peut pas
être libéral en économie en n'étant pas
libéral d'un point de vue politique et
la chine nous prouve au contraire ça
marche très très bien alors jusqu'à
quand la question qu'on peut se poser
c'est il ya une opacité et notamment une
opacité des bilans ddd des comptes des
sociétés chinoises et notamment aussi
toutes ces sociétés qui emploient des
cadres jeu leron les voilà les cadres du
parti communiste seul parti et le monde
du business et très il ya dans les deux
mille trois cents délégués que vous
voyez là sur la photo vous avez montré
vous avez beaucoup de délégués du parti
qui travaillent qui ont des fonctions
confortable dans des sociétés d'état ces
sociétés d'état sont déficitaires mais
le problème c'est qu'elles absorbent la
majorité des prêts faits par les banques
et banques en chine sont tout public et
donc c'est autant de moins pour les
petites entreprises qui par ailleurs se
développe beaucoup en chine qu'il ya une
pas cité de l'économie chinoise est tout
à fait atteint il ya des ambitions à
long terme ça c'est l' avantage celle
avantage de 4 d'une dictature
c'est à dire d'avoir des plans à 30 ans
à 40 ans donc c'est la route de la soie
donc on s'installe on s'est installé il
ya quelques années au pirée mais
maintenant sa salle à djibouti en salle
au pakistan on s'installe à s'élancer un
peu partout on a des grandes bases
logistiques très importante pour pour
faire ce commerce est route de cette
route de la soie
mais je remarque quand même je peux pas
savoir l'avenir mais je remarque quand
même qu'aujourd'hui quand vous êtes
riches en chine vous n'avez pas trop
confiance dans le système
je remarque quand vous devenez riche en
francs en chine qu'est ce que vous
faites la première chose que vous
demandez c'est un passeport australien
la première chose c'est vous envoyez vos
enfants étudier à l'étranger
ensuite vous demander un passeport et
vous essayez d'obtenir un passeport
australien
vous pouvez obtenir un passeport
français ou on l'est encore mieux voilà
ou américains et puis ensuite vous
mettez pas tout votre argent en chine
parce que vous avez pas si confiance que
ça dans le système bancaire chinois donc
je pense qu'en fait ce qu'on peut dire
alors il ya un modèle effectivement qui
marche bien mais comme d'ailleurs le
modèle stalinien a pendant un moment
avec sa dureté pas mal marché parce que
c'est le modèle salines et est allé
jusqu'à faire la bombe h et le spoutnik
mais ce qui fait quand même selon moi
vraiment développer les économies pour
de bon et des économies solides qui
peuvent par exemple résister à une
direction d'êta erratique comme on a aux
états unis vous êtes j on a une
direction d'êta qui est erratique 3 pour
personne ne comprend ce qui fait qu'ils
étaient unis continue parce que c'est
une société solide beau-parent pourquoi
parce que c'est un état de droit avec
des règles d'économie que tout le monde
connaît et sur transparent et que tout
le monde à date avec une véritable
justice aujourd'hui en chine c'est l'art
vite vous n'avez pas de recours elle
vous de personnes y compris les chinois
personne n'a confiance dans la justice
commerciale
s'il ya des fragilités n'empêche que
ces chinois ils sont plus puissants que
jamais ils ont des excédents commerciaux
monstrueux
cette montée en puissance est elle pas
inquiétante quand on voit tout ce que
les sites tout ce que les chinois
rachètent nous dit sophie des sujets
d'inquiétude qu'on peut avoir tous la
même chose la chine est devenu
effectivement une des toutes premières
puissances économiques mondiales avec
des mouvements qui sont capables
d'influer sur la forme ça dépendra
vraiment en compte c'est ça oui est ce
que demandent les eaux la chine a
dépensé par habitant ou si c'est un pib
global
oui j'en ai pas tous les chiffres en
tête mais en revanche qui se passe en
chine est capable aujourd'hui d'influer
sur l'ensemble de
de l'écosystème mondial et donc de ceux
conduits là c'est très important et un
petit point qui est intéressant dans le
disque au café le président chis et qu'
il n'a pas donné cette fois ci
l'objectif de croissance qui était une
tradition chez les présidents chinois où
on arrivait dans le congrès avec des
plans et c'est en lisant mon objectif
c'est de faire 6 nba % de croissance
là il n'a pas donné de chiffres
évidemment il veut continuer à avoir de
la croissance mais ça veut bien dire que
ce modèle chinois il est en train de
basculer ou cette croissance qu'on
allait chercher avant à toute force par
l'exportation en particulier
aujourd'hui on cherche à avoir un petit
rééquilibrage quand même avec plus de
consommation et plus de 2
création de richesses à l'intérieur de
la chine pour faire continuer à faire
monter cette classe moyenne dont
l'enrichissement est aussi une clé de la
stabilité sociale et l'on revient au
sujet au sujet politique après il ya des
gros points de fragilité qui sont
effectivement les sociétés d'état qui
sont terriblement sous productives et
donc sur lesquels il a encore énormément
de travail de rationalisation à faire et
ça c'est vrai ça ça va être fait et puis
on a le sujet de l'endettement des
entreprises privées aussi qui est devenu
un sujet considérables et qui inquiète à
l'échelle internationale pour la
stabilité du système financier puisque
effectivement là c'est la boîte noire
on se doute qu'il ya énormément de 2,2
crédit et dont on ne connaît pas très
bien les qualités en chine et que si un
jour cette bulle là devait devait
exploser on sait pas très bien quelles
seraient les conséquences et les les
voilà les conséquences sur sur le
système international de réunion je
souscris à tout ce qu'a dit c'est
absolument voilà la question aussi
importante c'est ça c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui les besoins de stabilité
à l'intérieur de cet immense empire et
que la croissance 7,7 ce grand bond
accéléré il faut aussi un moment donné
redistribuer écueil et des conditions
sociales qui puisse justement tempérer
tout ce que ça a pu avoir de violence et
qui a épargné personne et notamment les
classes moyennes et mais aujourd'hui il
ya une époque en chine on mourait de
faim en travaillant beaucoup maintenant
on arrive à vivre en travaillant
beaucoup voilà oui mais on arrive à
vivre 100 ans on classe voilà il ya
quelque chose qui kiffe et qui est une
gageur et qui est un défi aussi pour
l'avenir et la stabilité de la chine je
crois que les chinois sont pas tournés
vers l'extérieur et non pas une
politique d'expansion je parle sous
contrôle de mon voisin bien sûr mais en
revanche
le contre-exemple parfait pour eux c'est
comme l'appellation pardon effectivement
il ya cette politique d'expansion par
les rachats alors qu'il y à vocation à
être amené à l'intérieur aussi parce que
c'est l'acquisition de technologies ou
deux roues de savoir quand et où j'ai
effectivement on a des sujets assez
sensible de rachats d'entreprises en
occident parler
par exemple tout cas ils ont réussi à
acheter ça ni merkel ni mac ont pu
s'opposer
il y aura des chinois ont acheté la plus
grande société allemande de robots et
c'est assez inquiétant parce qu'en fait
c'est très bien ce qui se passe quand
les européens ont attaqué par le marché
chinois où enfin la compétition mondiale
ensemble il ya siemens par exemple qui a
aidé qui a vendu la technologie du tgv
au chinois et aujourd'hui nous avons un
groupe siemens alstom pour le transport
ferroviaire qui se retrouvent qui se bat
contre le chinois que siemens à aider et
à 10 ans est donc en fait effectivement
il ya un vol de technologies
systématique et les européens sont et
sens aux forces sont sourds extrêmement
naïf si vous voulez on a quand même le
sentiment est qu'il ya un changement de
ton par rapport à la chine parce que
avant on disait c'est avant tout des
horribles au dictateur qui opprime le
tibet terra là on dit quand même ils
sont très performants économiquement ils
ont sorti le tiers du pays de la misère
fait centaines de millions de gens
fêtent leur avons la chine finalement
non faites la part du réalisme mercredi
on a bien vu que depuis l'arrivée de
macron il ya une légère réorientation de
du discours philosophique de la
diplomatie française qui pour le dire
très très vite donne raison donne plus
raison à renaud girard dans son réalisme
qui signe j'ai rien car frédéric encel
dans son idéalisme disons
néoconservateurs où ils saunier ainsi
vous voulez donc ça je crois que ledit
la wii la réorientation du discours sur
la chine qui est quand même une des plus
horribles dictatures de la planète un
peu d'erreurs
rappelons le elle est due au fait que
macron a décidé par gaullisme barney au
gaullisme de renouer avec une vision
plus réaliste des relations
internationales n'empêche que le
théorème qu'on a balayé d'un revers de
main à l'instant en dix ans pardon
finalement capitalisme et démocratie ne
vont pas toujours de pair
c'est vrai l'exemple du turbocapitalisme
chinoise c'est un exemple de réussite
hautement capitalistiques et très peu
démocratique
mais sur la durée je pense en revanche
que c'est ce que renault suggérait quand
vous avez une sortie de la paupérisation
grande masse de gens qui accède au bas
de la classe moyenne
ils adoptent peu à peu les idéaux
démocratiques sur ce plan là le
paradigme le modèle intellectuel cac
avait donné francis fukuyama au moment
de la chute du mur de berlin en fin de
l'histoire mais il reste juste
c'est-à-dire que quand vous sortez de la
misère que vous accédez à une forme de
stabilité petite bourgeoise puis ensuite
bourgeoise évidemment que vous adoptez
les idéaux planétaire de la démocratie
on va dire en gros américaines et
européennes et donc à terme le tigre le
méchant tigre le méchant tir tir en
chinois sera bloquée dans son expansion
s'ils continuent effectivement dans la
voie de la démocrature et ne se tournent
pas vers une authentique démocratie mais
ça peut prendre un siècle
le basculement entre le basculement sur
le la façon dont on voit la chine c'est
aussi les aussi parallèle de l'ue moment
on renvoyait la chine comme un marché
sur laquelle on avait envie de vendre
tous nos produits au moment où
effectivement la chine est devenu un
concurrent
et ça a quand même fait énormément
basculer la vision diplomatique on
pouvait avoir de la chine sur le terrain
économique en tout cas je vous re se
passer à un autre et dernier sujet à
part ationale le l'état islamique dont
la capitale est ra qu'à raqqa dans les
forces de syriennes ont annoncé hier que
l avait été libéré alors est ce que
c'est la fin
de neige eh bien écoutez c'est pas
forcément l'avis de tout le monde en
particulier ça n'est pas le l'avis
d'arnaud danjean à un jeu d'argent
il est député européen les républicains
mais il est surtout président du comité
de la revue stratégique qui connaît bien
ce succès sujet et il était ce matin sur
france inter la fin je suis pas sûr
qu'on la voie de notre vivant s'il
voulait parce que quand même s'il
faisait la famille arrive c'est une
idéologie extrêmement virulente c'est
une idéologie qui concerne des centaines
de milliers voire des millions de
personnes et donc qui se nourrit en plus
de beaucoup de facteurs des facteurs
sociologiques sociétaux même lourd dans
certains pays
donc c'est pas quelque chose qu'on va
éradiquer comme ça militairement a
fortiori donc la lutte anti terroriste
c'est une lutte de longue haleine
en général vous connaissez très bien
cette région vous avez couvert ce
conflit et d'autres pour le figaro est
ce que vous croyez effectivement que
état islamique n'est pas prêt de ceux de
disparaître en tout cas peut-être pas
géographiquement mais idéologiquement
d'abord et toujours quand est ce que
vous avez dit viser les forces syriennes
se sont les fds les forces démocratiques
cn qui sont pas les forces syriennes du
gouvernement de dalles vachin et les
forces les fds donc les forces
démocratiques cn sont en très grande
partie sont en fait des forces kurdes
mais avec quelques arabes parce que
comme jaca est une ville arabe
on va confier aux arabes la police de
rackham et enfin la force de frappe qui
a repris à cassette une force jaune avec
les deux obsessions avec l'un des
américains
les objets qu merci pour cette précision
vraie correction wallon le nom mais bon
on comprenne bien
alors voilà non mais évidemment c'est
parce que c'est la fin c'est une scène
c'est une politique assez intelligente
de la part des américains de cette
famille vraiment en première et en
deuxième en deuxième rideau ou si vous
voulez et d'avoir suscité ces fds et
forces démocratiques syriennes le qui ça
se passe assez bien
on ne va pas du tout vers un kurdistan
parce que par ailleurs vous avez un
échec total de la politique de base
années en irak mais on pourra y revenir
mais c'est un petit peu compliqué mais
on va vers des américains qui ont su où
il faut le reconnaître susciter des
forces locales pour éliminer dette mais
bien sûr que les les djélis savent
s'évanouir dans la nature ça va
disparaître pour pour réapparaître
ailleurs alors 13 à un moment ait quitté
ils ont beaucoup quitter la série pour
resurgir en libye moment même il leur
suffisait de prendre turkish airlines
est allé prendre le vol il tend à zoom
istanbul tripoli aujourd'hui on fait
attention à 7 à cette fille aime et qui
existait il ya d'autres postes qui vont
ce que se constituer mais c'est une
première victoire mais je suis d'accord
avec grand avec un autre agent c'est
c'est une c'est une guerre de 100 ans et
une guerre de c'est une guerre de
civilisation c'est d'une guerre profonde
c'est une guerre très importante parce
que c'est une guerre aussi
d'éducation alors vous avez des gens qui
ont essayé de faire changer ça vous avez
le président si si qui va bientôt
arriver en france il arrive le président
égyptien arrive lundi en france qui a
dans son discours à la mosquée d'al
azhar a dit qu'il fallait que la
religion et intègre la sphère privée et
qui va avec l'islam sunnite pense à se
réformer alors que lui même est un pieux
musulman donc ça c'est important
mais mon sentiment mon sentiment c'est
qu'en fait vous avez comme à grand
bassin à cause de tous ses pétrodollars
sowa abyss qui était exporté un grand
bassin de salafistes et deux frères
musulmans dans l'islam ya pas que ça
bien sûr il ya un grand bassin deux
frères musulmans et de salafistes et mon
problème c'est que pour moi
un jihadiste c'est un salafiste ou c'est
un frère musulman qu'on voudrait en
phase terminale c derrière quelqu'un qui
va jusqu'au bout de son engagement voilà
le problème c'est que les appels d
origine
voilà le problème c'est que le terreau
idéologique vers le salafisme lui il
reste assez présent et peut-être même
assez conquérant au sein même de l'islam
c'est l'avis de l'islamologue richard
benzini les nice matin sur europe 1
écoutez vous dites plus les prédicateurs
interdisent des choses et plus ils ont
de succès oui absolument parce qu'on a
l'impression que l'islam dit authentique
serait celui qui serait le maximum
normes et est donc plus il ya de normes
et plus vous êtes musulman pour revenir
à la voix de dieu vous allez mettre en
place un certain nombre de normes qui
vont créer cette communauté virtuelle et
finalement qui finit par enfermer les
individus les encastrer dans cette
communauté avec cette idée de la pureté
pipi de la pureté à la purification le
passage peut être très vite en tout cas
en terme de processus de violence
je vous voyais à prouver qu'il a raison
belle façon ce qu'il veut décrire
fidèlement la situation juste que d'ici
là ce que vient de dire renault rno le
connaît extrêmement bien le terrain on
peut ajouter pour donner un argument
fait grandir une arme de plus pour
décrypter cette situation c'est très
bien réjouissons-nous racaille tomber
c'est formidable il est évident que
l'état islamique en tant que tel et
quand même fragilisé mais pour autant je
suis aussi d'accord avec don
il n'ya pas d'éradication possible
pourquoi car le problème est
effectivement culturelle et idéologique
et ce n'est pas une guerre de
civilisation au sens naturellement ou
l'ont entendu des gens comme george
deubeuliou bouge
il ne s'agit pas d'une opposition si
vous voulez entre le monde de l'islam et
le monde occidental disons chrétien ou
post chrétiens il s'agit d'abord d'une
guerre civile au sein même des sociétés
arabo musulmanes et s'il a bien sûr que
benzin dit l'essentiel
il y a deux visions au fond de l'islam
qui se font face il ya ce qu'on a appelé
si certains français autour de revues
comme la règle du jeu dont on pariait
disons un moment sur cet islam des
lumières on pensait qu'avec benzin des
gens que abdennour bidar ou abdelwahab
meddeb et ça n'a pas marché à tomber ou
ayaan hirsi ali pouvais tu les vois de
cet islam des lumières de même que ça
qui n'est que nous avions défendu avec
lamy valérie mais ça va ça va marcher
attendez vous rigolez ça ça marche en
partie non ça heureusement oui non non
mais ça marche lentement sa marche
lentement cercle il y a effectivement
aujourd'hui des démocrates dans l'islam
ce sont en gros c'est les gens qu'on a
cité et leurs relais dans les différents
pays mais ils sont face à des théocrates
et je suis d'accord avec renault était
au crac qui sont des millions qui sont
qui sont des millions qui sont des
centaines de millions donc il l'esprit
frères musulmans il a essaimé au delà de
toutes les espérances de raphaël balland
c'est une évidence
donc aujourd'hui reprendre le fil de
cette estime des démocrates c'est
absolument nécessaire
il faut savoir que ça prendra du temps
je suis évidemment d'accord aussi avec
donjon sur ce point bercy va ya la
question que je me pose c'est
effectivement dans quelle mesure cette
défaite militaire
de l'état islamique a un impact ou pas
sur l'image que peut renvoyer l'état
islamique à ceux qui peuvent être tentés
par son idéologie et donc la capacité
locale est le don quelle mesure le
pouvoir d'attraction de dèche sûr
de jeunes musulmans que ce soit dans la
zone et dans nos dans nos pays à nous
est ce que ce pouvoir d'attraction est
atteint ou pas aujourd'hui
voilà je crains que cette défaite à jaca
ne suffisent pas et que les images de
deux défaites militaires ne suffisent
pas avoir un impact et est donc on en a
fini avec ce sujet la voile à lorient
vous aurez mot de la fin ce que vous
partagez ce pessimisme ambiant
oui en tout cas je suis pas optimiste
parce que l'islamisme et le fanatisme il
est polymorphe daishin branche y en a
d'autres
il ya énormément de mouvance aujourd'hui
ils ont quitté jaca ils vont se
disperser ce disparaître pourrait
apparaître ça toujours été l'idée est
idéologiquement ils ont jamais été aussi
fort enfin je veux dire comme deezer
nous très justement il y avait ceux il y
avait l'appel vers cham le pays
cet état se khalifa qui était un
objectif aujourd'hui ils vont retomber
sur leurs pattes différemment
idéologiquement et donc reconstruire un
discours qui s'adaptera à une nouvelle
génération
ils continueront d'ailleurs et pour une
continuer à frapper sur le terrain cela
sous la forme d'actions plus type
terroriste
voilà attentats etc et puis je prenais
plus aux périodes en somalie on n'a pas
compris voilà et puis dans le reste du
monde ils vont reconstituer aussi des
bases donc non je crois que c'est
ils ont une grande adaptabilité et que
malheureusement je pense qu'ils vont
continuer à le montrer
et puis c'est vrai que la fin du raid du
territoriale qui est qui viendra un
temps du cours des dix-huit n'empêche
pas la mise en place de la stratégie que
kepel a décrites dans ces livres qui
sont et non pour ça vraiment lycée
malraux capelle voilà il décrit cette
stratégie du gianni de troisième
génération d'accord on a plus de khalifa
dommage bon c'est vrai qu'on sait mais
on aimait bien être en irak et en syrie
c'est pas grave on recrute parmi les
populations civiles européennes des
combattants qui sont que comme vous et
moi des nike bauer boys et diebold
eux mêmes et ça évidemment c'est quelque
chose qui est extrêmement redoutable je
crois merci beaucoup merci beaucoup à
tous les quatre surtout restez connectés
juste après point de vue à suivre un
live exceptionnel sur lefigaro.fr avec
un jeune chanteur plein de promesses il
s'appelle julien clerc bonsoir
[Musique]